come back everyone it's my great
pleasure to introduce our next speaker
we are very fortunate to have Noah Dagan
with us today Noah is uh the head of
data and AI driven medicine at the
clalet research institute and she's on
the faculty at bgu and she has a PHD in
computer science and an MD and
specializes in public health and so her
work puts together all of these
different domains of expertise and thank
you for being here uh Noah and we look
forward to hearing
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for the invitation to speak in the
workshop
um
so
it's it's actually interesting because
the things I'm going to talk about are
really related to topics that were
already discussed this morning uh but I
think that maybe the difference is that
I'll be speaking about them from the
perspective of a healthcare organization
so cleat is a healthcare organization in
Israel we treat over half of the Israeli
population
and for the past decade or so we've been
using prediction models pretty
ubiquitously for many different things
and for many different clinical
conditions and from that experience
we've encountered all sorts of
requirements and things that we need to
or standards that we need to live up to
when we try to deploy these models in
practice so uh we'll also discuss
special considerations uh of prediction
models specifically in healthcare
medicine and the two things that we
agree basically focusing on is fairness
and explainability which are two things
that are as was already discussed this
morning are essential in many domains
but in medicine they are very important
as well so as a basic outline we'll
start with a few examples of prediction
models in medicine specifically
prediction and also that we actually use
to treat patients in skeletal services
and then we'll talk a bit about fairness
considerations
some collaborations that we've had with
academic Partners regarding these
aspects and finally we'll discuss some
explainability issues and the different
trade-offs again uh in a pretty related
manner to what was already presented but
from a different point of view a very
practical one and the different kind of
models that we chose to use
for different uh settings uh during the
covid-19 pandemic
so we'll start with the few examples of
prediction models in medicine and why
they they are so essential so this is an
article that was published really a few
weeks ago and it really summarizes the
need so neatly that I had to to
reference it
basically it says that in order for
Primary Care practitioners Physicians to
do everything that is expected from them
by guidelines they need to to work
almost 27 hours a day
and specifically uh 14 hours a day from
these 27 hours
will be devoted for preventive care
again if they want to adhere to every
guideline and make sure that every
patient in their what we call in Israel
in their list basically gets everything
that they should according to the
various preventive guidelines so it's I
think obvious to everyone that this is
not feasible and if we try to achieve
this
pursue of these guidelines the the the
end will end up with many patients that
will not receive what they need to and
how we choose the different patients
that will or will not receive the
preventive guidelines will probably be
some random process
and nothing that is really systematic in
any manner so
this is why we think that quantitative
models and specifically prediction
models in medicine are so essential
because basically they allow us to shed
a spotlight on a side group of patients
that are specifically high risk for some
clinical condition
and we can shed different spotlights
like this one for different conditions
so for example for one disease it will
be one group of patients and for a
different disease that we want to
prevent it will be a different group of
patients and that group of patients will
be much more
targeted and the average risk within
that subwoofing patients will be
relatively higher to that that exist in
direct in the general population
hopefully making the interventions the
preventive interventions both more
visible because the counts will just be
smaller and also
probably what we think and from our
experience it's actually the case we'll
be able to increase adherence to these
guidelines because once you tell the
positions or the GPS to focus on a
subset of patients
in a number that is much more manageable
then there is a much higher chance that
they'll actually be able to get to a
substantial proportion of individuals in
that subgroup so this is why we use
spotlights in medicine and this is why
it's so important to us to be able to
define those patients at risk for
different various future or even current
conditions
so as one very practical example
that we use on a daily basis in CLE
Elite
osteoporetic fractures I imagine that if
I tell most of you that this this is a
condition that we are working very hard
to prevent uh you're wondering why
because there are so many conditions and
so many frightening conditions that you
may need to be worried about but not
many people think about osteopotic
factors in that in that way and that is
just wrong
and I'm motivation to predict
specifically this disease is first that
it's a preventable disease so if we
predict the risk we we actually can do
something about high-risk patients and
the second reason is that this disease
is a very high burden disease
um the incidence is relatively High I
imagine that everyone in the room knows
someone that's after suffered an
osteoporic Factor but the thing that
people are less aware of is that the
mobility and mortality of this disease
is also very substantial so for elderly
individuals that sustain
a fracture of the of the femur neck that
the thing that is plotted in this
diagram the chance that they will not
survive this year is about 20 and the
chance that they will survive the the
year but will stay
um uh have some limited uh capacity and
they will not just return to the
independent Independence that they had
before the fracture is another 20 or 30
percent so the amount of individuals
that will deteriorate substantially
following this kind of factor is really
enormous and this is something that we
really want to prevent that these
numbers are much higher compared to most
types of cancer for example
so this is something that we really want
to prevent and the the advantages that
we have in this case is that formal
guidelines formal clinical guidelines
recognize the importance of these
prediction models specific specifically
for this disease and this is not the
case for almost any other medical
condition except for maybe
cardiovascular conditions so this is
something that is very feasible it's
very important and we deal with it again
on a daily basis and I can also say that
uh this is an example of a paper in
which we demonstrate that in order to
get to Accurate predictions for
osteoporetic factors you can also use CT
scans that were done for any other
reason and if if you integrate the data
from the clinical record and the Imaging
studies then you can get even better
predictions and this is something that
is again has a lot of Merit in terms of
how to treat patients better but this is
one example second example that I would
give touches on Hepatitis C so hepatitis
C is a type of virus but as opposed to
other types of viruses that we know like
say covid-19 this type of virus is once
you're infected with it can become a
chronic condition in which the body
cannot
uh eliminate the disease and then over
the years what happens is that the liver
can be substantially damaged not causing
either cancer or of the liver or hepatic
failure and
this is something that's up until a few
years ago was not something that we had
very effective way of handling but
starting for from around 2013
uh and in the years that followed that
we had we started to uh have in our
basket of treatments treatments that are
very effective against this disease
treatments that as opposed to uh years
before that uh do not have uh
substantial side effects there they are
given for a course of say 12 weeks it
depends on the on the specific type of
hepatitis A but let's say for
something like 12 weeks and the
relegation rates are more than 97 and
that's amazing because up until recent
years uh the the treatments that we did
have were
both very
um I had a lot of side effects and were
not so efficient the the reduction rate
was something like 50 so this is an
enormous opportunity that we now have
and the World Health Organization starts
to speak in terms of of eliminating this
disease as a public health threat or as
something that is substantial for public
health because if we can identify
patients
that are not known to be active carriers
then we can now treat them and maybe
prevent the disease to be passed to
other individuals and also save the
lives of these patients who we identify
and treat
and the problem is
that it is estimated that around 50 of
those who are infected are undiagnosed
so no one is aware of that fact that
they are chronic areas of Hepatitis C so
we cannot treat them and when I say no
one I mean both the individual and the
Healthcare System
so that means that if we want to
eradicate this disease we have to do
some sort of screening in order to
identify those individuals at risk and
the way we chose
um up until now to do this screening in
Clinical Services is to start by
targeting the individuals that are at
the highest risk because we want to
maximize the amount of individuals that
we identify as early as possible so we
can actually create them and hopefully
save their life and prevent those
outcomes that they've just mentioned
so you can imagine that the way that
we're doing that is to go back in time
uh recruit a retrospective cohort of
patients that were not tested for
hepatitis C up until that point in time
and then follow these patients identify
the very small proportion of patients
that will end up being positive
in the in the lab tests and will be
relevant for treatment
and then basically take that outcome
across that with uh hundreds of
variables from the medical method uh
sometimes we do it with more than
hundreds of variables even thousands of
variables and then we create a
prediction model that it helps us to
identify patients who are at a
specifically high risk for
um
hepatitis C so
speaking about explainability and the
specific importance of excellent
explainability in prediction models in
medicine the first model that we've
created in this case was a simple
decision Tree in all to it basically
create something that's policy makers
and Physicians can relate to can really
understand in a manner that is not just
as was discussed some post-hoc
explainability method but something that
is very transparent and can be really
readily understood for every patient
and the nice thing about that is that
even though
this process is done uh through ml
methods the the model identifies the
same kinds of variables that if that if
you were to ask
um an expert
which are the most important risk
factors the first things that are listed
in this decision tree will be the
factors that that expert will describe
so this is something that is very
helpful when we try to convince these
Physicians and policy makers to adopt
these kinds of models because they can
really trust when they see that the
first thing that they see in these
decision trees are something that they
understand they can trust the maybe the
the lower parts of the trees that are
sometimes not written in the textbooks
that they were taught
and after we get there uh say their
trust and we can ask them to do a leap
of faith and and go to something that is
more black box uh in this case it was an
extra boost model and uh something that
make the decision more accurate when
it's based on many many trees
um that ran together to to create a
final accommodation recommendation for
each patient
and it's also very helpful when we make
the performance measures very
explainable uh for policy makers as well
so we just don't just say the AUC is 92
percent we try to visualize the the
effect of using such models so in this
this case we try to
visualize the fact that the outcome rate
is very very small and so it's a very
unbalanced problem in machine learning
lingo and we try to demonstrate what
happens if we focus the screening on a
subset of patients how the overlap
between those who are positive and those
who are identified by the algorithm for
screening is obviously not random but is
um there's a large overlap and even if
we screen only say six percent of the
population will be able to identify 72
percent of the positive carriers
um and that means so it could be
referred to as the recall measure or
sensitivity as we call it in in medicine
and that is something that they can
really relate to and understand and
I can happily say that that is the case
in in many of the prediction models that
we bring to their table and for their
decisions uh and they really understand
the power of these tools and now it's
even much more
um
it's much easier for us to to basically
explain these kinds of models they
already gained experience of using them
they understand them and they are eager
to adopt them so we have many of these
prediction models in
in production incredit and these models
some of them run on a daily basis some
of them run when they when it's relevant
say for example the allocation of flu
vaccines every year for many years now
uh has been assisted by a prediction
model so that runs uh annually in other
models that you see here on the screen
uh basically around on a daily basis
but once we create these models again
and we put them into practice we
understand that it's not just something
that we can develop
use whatever package that there is out
there gets to a reasonable performance
measure measures and just put it into
production when we deploy these kinds of
models to for use specifically in
medicine we have to worry about various
things uh which are not just the basic
performance measures so the first
example that I will give you is
something that is from the world of
fairness
and the organizers of the workshop have
asked
described a collaboration that we've had
with this respect uh and so here it goes
basically so fairness in medicine I
think
I don't even have to say it but
um
uh just for the good order of things I
will parents in medicine is not
something that is related to models so
fairness in medicine is is something
that is discussed all the time with
respect to
um
inequalities or
um access to resources that may have
been uneven across groups in in society
and fairness in medicine is something
that is basic it's something that
everyone speaks about
completely regardless of models but when
we create prediction models in medicine
when we deploy them for medical practice
we have to hold the same standards that
at the other medical
professionals and the other aspects of
medical domains
uh requiring this in this respect so
when we talk about prediction models in
medicine and specifically
regarding fairness I think basically the
question that we're asking ourselves is
even though we've used the prediction
model and we've did a
a much better job compared to the very
general guidelines that were used in
order to say select patients for
preventive
um interventions before the prediction
model so now we're much more
individualized we identify a side group
of patients in a much higher risk so
it's obviously much better for the
individual patient but the question is
with respect to fairness measure
measures is is the personalized risk
personalized enough so uh specifically
if we train a model and we see and we
look at the performance measures we look
at the AUC we look at the different
cutoff specific
performance measures like I don't know
Precision or recall or positive
predictive value or sensitivity
respectively uh the different terms in
medicine for machine learning terms
basically we usually look
on the average
across the entire training set or the
test set whatever we choose to to
evaluate usually we do not take the
extra steps of making sure that the
performance measures hold when we look
at specific minority groups and the
model when it optimizes whatever
optimization function was defined
looks on the average of the population
so it may happen that's for minority
groups the predictions will be less
accurate or non-accurate
and the question is what do we mean when
we say accurate what performance
measures do we care mostly about and
which performance measures should we
test in some populations and there is no
one right answer here so we have
discrimination measures like the AUC or
the sensitivity record for specific
catalogs we have specific specificity
measures the positive predictive value
the negative predictive values all with
respect for to specific titles and we
also have the calibration measures
that's not just test the rankings by
proportions but actually make sure that
the average predicted rate or risk
is correlated to The observed risk so
that if we say that the risk is I say 15
then
if we take 100 individuals with that
average risk we'll end up having 15 on
average patients that actually will have
the relevant outcome so that there is a
good correlation between the average
predicted risk and The observed risk
and again there's no just one correct
measure but I will say in a minute which
measures we think are more important
with respect to prediction models in
medicine
so this is not a new problem in a more
simplistic manner this is something that
was brought to Medical journals for
discussions and with many criticism
criticisms many years ago so this is an
article that is more than 20 years old
and this article basically describes how
a specific cohort of patients which is
called the Mesa cohort multi-ethnic
study of Hotel sclerosis was recruited
in order to develop prediction models
for cardiovascular diseases so in this
case it's it's simple regressions it's
not actually boost models and it's not
neural networks it's something that was
much more simplistic but was used used
ubiquitous ubiquitously in
cardiovascular
um domains in order to identify patients
that are candidates for specific
treatments to prevent that
cardiovascular disease and the reason
that this uh Mesa cohort was recruited
in order to develop with risk scores
was that previous uh calculators like
the Framingham calculator which is a
very very famous prediction model in
cardiovascular disease in medicine were
criticized to be non-accurate for women
and for ethnicity groups other than
Caucasians so basically most of these
models were in the beginning
developed on cohorts of Caucasian males
and it was they were criticized that
they are not accurate for other
groups in the society that are less
represented so the way that they chose
to address this problem is to recruit a
specific cohort in which there is they
make sure that there is enough
representation for the different
subpopulations that they want to make
sure that the models are accurate for on
average
but the problem is that if we have more
than one such protected variables and if
we want to protect more variables that
as a society we think we need to address
then pretty soon the number of
categories within those pictures the
protected features that we want to
um to make sure to test the performance
measures with respect to these
subpopulations pretty soon we get to a
number of sub-populations that is not
feasible for specific recruitment so we
have to use other
methods in order to make sure that we
create prediction models that are
accurate with respect to these cell
populations
so in this collaboration
um with these guys and specifically uh
guy rotloom and later on Marengo we
basically tried to
learn from their experience of studying
these problems in a theoretical Manner
and creating algorithms for
multi-calibration in order to to make
sure that the models are calibrated with
respect to different subpopulations in
the training set simultaneously
so why did we choose to focus on this
specific work and specifically on
calibration measures and the answer is
that in medicine many of the guidelines
when they take prediction models or
predicted risk into account what they
refer to is the absolute risk that means
that they usually set a specific cut off
and say that if the predicted risk is
over of some percentage say 7.5 percent
in cardiovascular recognitions for the
decision of whether or not to treat the
patient with statins for example that's
a drug that is used to reduce
cholesterol levels then
the guide I say or the guidelines refer
to the absolute priest and if that
absolute risk is being predicted
accurately and then and safe for that
patient uh the risk is indeed 99.3 and
the and the model identified that risk
accurately then predict patients the
decision the medical decision of whether
or not to start statins as a treatment
will be the correct decision but if we
have a patient from a minority group
that was less represented in the
training set and for that Minority the
product is not accurate and say that the
publicto identified identifies the risk
of the patient as 6.4 percent and that's
not the correct uh actual risk of that
patient
then we may choose the wrong pathway for
the treatment of that patient so this
this is why we really care about
absolute risks specifically in medicine
and this is why we care about model
calibration
so in order to
really make sure that indeed there is a
problem that we need to fix and we're
just not pursuing something that is not
really a problem we went back to the
world of cardiovascular predictions and
specifically to a product which is
called the pulled cohort equations
that's like the modern version of the
planning game score the type this
described
and we took a population of credit
members
over one million of them which are
relevant
with regards to the inclusion and
exclusion criteria for that predictor
and he said that different predictors
that are used to predict at risk and you
see that protected the specific
protected features that we've chosen to
evaluate the different performance
measures with respect to these
sub-populations
and
the first thing we found out that after
a very simplistic the adjustment to
Israeli rates of cardiovascular outcomes
the model is very well calibrated you
see it sits on the diagonal of the plot
that with respect to the predicted
versus observe risk and
usually honestly we stopped here we said
okay this this looks good uh the plot
seems good the the the the quantitative
measures are close to one uh which means
that we have good calibration we should
be satisfied and maybe feel comfortable
deploying this model into production
but the thing is that once you go into
those hundreds of sub-populations that
can be defined by those five protected
features that we've
um uh that we saw in the previous slide
then what we see is that for the average
It is Well calibrated but when you look
at specific subpopulations 20 percent of
them actually have a calibration in
large values that are smaller than 0.8
and another 20 percent have calibration
in the large values of more than 1.5
that means that very loud a very large
number of groups self operations that
we've defined by those protected
pictures get very unaccurate results
very uncalibrated results and that is
something that is is not good obviously
and in a different way of plotting this
here we've plotted each such stub group
has a different dot on the x-axis
and and here the the the the the the
y-axis in the is in the log scale so
here perfect calibration is zero and you
can see that many many sub populations
uh have very poor calibration with the
largest population which is the entire
population on the left and the smaller
sub population on the right so it's the
is you see some Trend uh in which when
the star population is smaller the
calibration measures are as expected
even worse
um and in this case we took the
algorithm that was suggested by Herbert
Johnson and Al and we've implemented it
so this algorithm is basically a post
process algorithm
uh that does something that is uh um
very simple I think it's beautiful how
simple it is it basically iterates
through this different sub population
and as long as there is a subpopulation
in which the
um the average of the prediction is uh
uh
um far enough from the
um observed rate of the disease in that
sub population then the algorithm which
is a post-processing algorithm that
basically nudges the predictions of that
sub population with respect to the
difference that we've observed and they
have
um
um
nice groups in in these publications of
why uh this basically
um will start running at some point uh
and every sub population in the
um in the training set will be
calibrated below that threshold of
Tolerance that we've defined
um and that's that's not
um that's not obvious because many
individuals simultaneously are
simultaneously
defined by different type of relations
so for a specific individual it can be
the case that's in different
Integrations of the loop they will be
shifted with the predictions back and
forth until they settle on a specific
prediction that satisfy this this
condition for the entire cell
populations that they belong to
simultaneously
and uh honestly uh being the the
Practical people who Implement these
things when we saw this academic
theoretical algorithm we're pretty
skeptical that actually it will actually
converge and actually finish running and
that it will actually manage to do what
it promises to do and we were really
Amazed by these results in which the
calibration in the test set was much
much better for All Star populations
after running this algorithm so this is
uh in the density plot of the different
subgroups
of patients that already fine but with
those variables and this is the
difference the second plot that we've
saw
um we call it in medicine it looks like
an EEG an abnormal EEG but we call it an
age of blood so everything was much
better uh with respect to this spot as
well so and and if we wanted in the
quantitatively manner the variance of
the calibration in the large values
between the cell population was actually
reduced by 90 more than 99 and for us it
was amazing and this is something that
if you want to read more about you can
you can find it here this is something
that we are actually implementing these
days as part of the
um uh ml
automatic ml processes that we have in
order to create prediction models in
Philly this is now integrated as a
post-processing step to every prediction
model that we will create in the future
so this is an example of how Academia
meets practical needs and does so in a
manner that is very practical and
actually affects patients lives so for
us it was an amazing collaboration and
and we're very fortunate to to be
encouraged to meet those people and to
become part of that
community that tries to think about
fairness with respective prediction
models in medicine
uh the third topic that I will discuss a
question uh yeah sure
uh yeah sorry I maybe missed this where
did the subgroups come from like domain
knowledge uh Physicians observing
miscalibration like how did you decide
these sensitive attributes to uh
then plug into multi calibration
so this is a good good question and an
interesting one so this is uh this was
defined by by social values if you mean
these are the the features that people
think about when they talk about
minority groups but if you ask me as a
clinician what I'm really interested in
now is to try these things out not just
for these protected pictures that
Society defines as protective features I
want to also try this out for clinical
pictures to test whether the prediction
is accurate for a minority groups which
is a clinical minority group and this is
something that we plan to do by the way
they're they're
um their paper and their algorithm is
Reading in a manner that is oblivious to
the to the set of of groups and to how
you define those groups uh it can be
done by any set of subgroups uh within
that that can be defined by features in
the subset that the individual set that
it has but for us in this first run of
this real was like Society considered
features and in future in the future I
think it will do the same for clinical
pictures and see what that does to the
model
I have one more question uh you're gonna
come to explainability next but I was
already wondering whether this
post-processing step uh you know uh
possibly worsens what the uh what the
decision tree might look like so are you
just changing the probabilities and
beliefs of the decision tree or are you
making bigger changes and is that
something that's taken into
consideration
so that's a really really great question
um basically what happens behind the
scenes is what I said is that
predictions are being moved back and
forth uh so it can definitely affect
things and it can definitely affect
things like explainability but the
question is because it basically it
changes the algorithm but it it depends
on how you treat sustainability so for
us in many cases what we do when it's a
black box model we do a very uh
simplistic explainability in which we
describe the risk factors that are
mostly understood by physicians that are
relevant for each patient and usually
for each patient we have at least one
two three major risk factors if that
patient was indeed identified as a very
high risk usually he or she have enough
major risk factors so that the clinician
will feel comfortable with identifying
that patient as a high risk patient but
that doesn't mean that the position
completely understand
the the process in a transmission in a
completely transparent fashion
and that actually
um connects really nicely to the next
part of the of the presentation in which
I will claim that the models should
always be explainable to an extent that
the position should be should feel
comfortable with the decision but
the way that the models are being used
and the purpose for which they were
developed changes the amount of
transparency that the model needs to
have so I will go to the next part and I
hope that you will understand what I
mean by that
so and and understand why in some
um circumstances it's okay just to
describe several risk factors that are
relevant for the patient just so the
clinician will have a an ability to to
make uh a relevant discussion with the
patient and and explain why we think
that he or she are at a specifically
high risk and why in other cases the
process needs to to be completely
transparent and then maybe uh messing
with the predictions in that manner uh
is something that will be more
challenging
so
I think it's clear and I don't need to
overstate why prediction models in
medicine need to be explainable we have
um decisions that could affect patients
lives and we don't want to do it uh in a
completely Black Box fashion
but to what extent it depends on the
actual use of the model and I'll try to
explain what I mean by that and I will
try to explain it to you by walking you
through our experience during the
covid-19 pandemic because things that
I'm saying now is things that we've
learned during the last two three years
and I don't think that three years ago I
would have been able to
um I don't think I would have told you
the same things but during the Kobe 9
pandemic the covid-19 pandemic we use
prediction models for more resource
allocation that we than we've ever used
before and during that the different
phases of the pandemic we understood
that we need different models for
different types of uses so
um
when we talk about prediction models
again we have that trade of of accuracy
and and maybe explosivity uh uh in which
complex and explosive models usually
have better performance usually they
have more uh granularity so they have
more and larger number of potential
intervention risk cutoffs but usually
they are less explainable even even if
we can as I say
um State a few risk factors that are
relevant for each patient it's never
completely transparent process and it
could affect the trust or acceptance
that different positions have towards
these models on the other end of the
spectrum
we have very simple models like
regressions for example or decision
trees in which the performance is
usually lower the number of potential
intervention cutoffs are sometimes
depending on the model can also be
smaller but the explainability is higher
and the trust and acceptance is also
usually higher and
I'll give you three different examples
on this spectrum all relevant to
prediction models and specifically to
the prediction of the risk of
being a patient that has a severe
disease once you will be affected by the
the
infected by the virus so we are talking
about severity risk prediction and
during the pandemic the need for this
um risk predictions usually basically
changed for the different resources that
we needed to allocate
so the first use case that we had was in
the very first weeks of the pandemic and
in Israel those were the very first
weeks in which we had patients and the
policy makers include requested that we
create a tool that will
um basically identify high-risk patients
and will create stratification of the
credit population so they will be able
to do some interventions that we'll see
in a few Styles the the challenge was
that uh and this is not that it's it's
not related specifically to
explainability but it's just interesting
and it's related to the previous part of
the talk so uh the the challenge was
that we didn't have individual level
data regarding covid-19 yet in Israel so
what we did is to create a prediction
model based on that flu predictor that
I've told you about that we run in in
every window because we thought that
it's reasonable to assume that another
infectious disease that affects the uh
the the lungs the pulmonary functions
could share the same risk factors as
that this new disease that we know
almost nothing about and we created this
um
blue predictor basically it was exactly
flu it was adjusted to be any serious
infectious disease that is a respiratory
respiratory infectious disease required
hospitalization and we identified the
predictors of this is shock values and
we identify the predict of the same
clinically very reasonable it identified
risk factors like age and smoking until
the vascular disease albumin which is
the major protein
um that that tells us something about
the Frailty of the person everything
seemed very reasonable and we had this
very granular model that ranks the
population with their respects to
encounter a severe respiratory infection
but it wasn't the covid-19 predictor in
any way but what we did have in those
days were epidemiological case fatality
rates from the chain Chinese CDC
and we really wanted to take these
numbers into consideration because uh
these numbers told us for example that
the diseases most of the Earth for males
and the disease is much more severe for
older individuals compared to younger
individuals in the manner that is not uh
in this like the same slope like other
respiratory conditions so we really want
to adjust the model the individual level
data model for the respiratory
infections to this new epidemiological
level data
um observations from different countries
and the interesting thing about it
is that the way we that we chose to do
it is using the same multi-calibration
algorithm that we already used for
furnace considerations before the
pandemic for completely different
outcomes so here it was not for fairness
um reasons it was just in order to shift
the prediction in a multi uh in in a
post-processing manner in a way that
will accommodate different uh targets
averages because a specific individual
for example can be logged simultaneously
to different age groups sex groups and
chronic condition groups so we use that
multi calibration outcome to adjust that
model to every piece of information that
we could put our hands on as of those
days and that was basically the first
predictor that we've created for severe
coffee 19. uh they have covid-19 data
and individual level data
in Israel uh seem to be doing a pretty
good War it was a black box model all
those shiftings uh did it completely
something weird that we've created
because we had to do something uh uh at
that time but retrospectively we saw
that for example it identified a very
high risk group of only eight percent of
the population but that eight percent of
individuals actually identified 73 of
those that ended up deteriorating and we
had several such certification groups so
I'm I'm doing it a bit uh quickly so we
can get to the end of the presentation
but basically the just trust me that the
prediction model had pretty good
performance measures and specifically
the calibration uh which was pretty nice
uh because of the basic product of the
respiratory infection you see it in
purple and instead of the calibration of
the predictor after uh the process of
using those
um uh Chinese measurements of case
fatality rate and you can see that not
very a very good calibration but if you
take into account the process that we
did here which we did not know it will
work or not it was a really reasonable
uh calibration uh for the type of
process that we created and this model
did a lot of heavy lifting we used it
for many many different
uh things during the the first months of
the pandemic in the very first weeks 200
000 Elite members received personal
phone calls from their clinics uh
telling them that they are at a high
risk for this this new disease how they
should uh watch yourselves how they
should contact the clinics if they need
something so they will not have to leave
their house and go to a clinical
facility that may have people that could
infect them uh once someone was already
infected we use this prediction model in
order to as a safety net uh to
hospitalized patients that seem
clinically well even though
um even though they think clinically
well we identify high-risk populations
as candidates for hospitalization
because the deterioration rates for that
very high risk group were more than 30
percent so they it was very very high
risk and we consider them as candidates
to be uh placed in the hospital just to
make sure as a safety net uh in that
case and the even if they were treated
at home because they are at a lower tier
risk then they will be contacted more
times a day according to the protocols
compared to other patients that were at
a lower predicted risk
um and so this is the first use case in
which we had a very expressive model it
was the Black Box model you can read
more about this and the thing about this
model is that's none of the resources
that we've allocated was super sensitive
because if a physician wanted to contact
the patient and and tell them that they
were at high risk because they think
they thought the model missed that
patient they would just pick up the
phone and call them uh it was not it was
a limited resource but not in the sense
that if a physician wanted to assign
that resource to an extra patient
someone will care about it same goes for
the hospital beds so the resource was
limited but not in a dramatically
fashion that that was
um very
um
tightly monitored let's say like that
and in that case a black box model in
which we just State some risk factors
for each patient just to make sure that
the positions and understand why that
patient was at a high risk that was good
enough
but then a few uh months later in the
middle of 2020 was in Israel it was the
end of the first lockdown and then there
was new Need for the risk of
certification tool for the use of the
general public people wanted to know
whether or not they were specifically
high risk whether they could return to
their jobs whether they can feel safe to
leave their house or meet their
grandchildren or whatever and then we
were asked to create a prediction model
that could be used by the general public
so it has to be very very very very
simple model that anyone can just use
and you do not need uh I don't know a
Linux server with 40
um
processors and whatever in order to run
the the model
um and here what we did is to create a
very simple model in which we created a
training set and a temporal tester but
we've
identified the major risk factors that
were known as risk factors as of then
for severe cov19 and we've by definition
said that each such risk factor will be
eluded one single risk point
for each risk factor and then we did a
lot of
um not very machine learning it process
in which we basically explode the
various risks on the average predicted
risk within different cutoffs of of age
groups and age groups and number of risk
points and the
um basically the interaction between
these Packers and then we manually
created cutoffs that I defined or or
stratified the population into different
risk groups and we've created plots that
stated that for example if you are over
the age of 70 and you have more than
four points risk points than you are at
a very high risk and if you are in
different age groups then it depends on
the amount of risk points that you have
and then we we've been able to stratify
the population in a very simplistic
manner into various risk
groups and each risk group
if when when you test this very
simplistic process in a temporal test
set you can see that it works pretty
well surprisingly well compared to the
Simplicity of the process and then we've
been able to really translate every
risk group into specific recommendations
taking into account the dissemination
rate in the local setting as of that
time and the specific activity whether
it's low risk activity or high risk
activity and then this was a very
simplified decision support to empower
different individuals to make the
decisions for themselves and this is in
Hebrew but this is how it was published
in the popular media in Israel so that
every individual can identify the risk
factors and basically Place themselves
in the risk group so this is in terms of
explainability something that is in the
spectrum of very very simple something
that can be used by the General Public
extremely transparent but has very low
granularity and and accuracy is
reasonable but but obviously not
something that we can do when we want to
allocate resource in the in the
non-granular fashion
and then came the beginning of 2022 in
which we had new covid-19 treatments
it's not the vaccinations it's the three
it's the treatments that you give
patients once they were already infected
and on a daily basis we had a need to
allocate these medical medications to
the highest risk patients
so this is something that has to be
fully transparent because now you you're
allocating something that is in Us in is
is really limited resource and you
cannot just choose to give it to expert
patients if you want to give it to extra
patients you have to have a very good
reason uh and and on the other hand
you need to create enough granularity to
accommodate the different levels of the
pandemic and the amount of medications
that you have each day so we understood
that the Black Box model cannot work in
this case and this very simplistic model
is not suitable either so we basically
created something in the middle
what we created is a logistic regression
model for severe disease and then we
took the uh the row coefficients and
translated them in a linear
transformation manner into points of
risk and what we came up with is another
method of risk points so it's completely
transparent it could be manually
calculated but it's not something that
could be presented to the general public
in a manner that individuals can just
sit in the news and and calculate the
risk in their heads it's something that
is more suitable for use of positions
and you can see the number of risk
points that are assigned to each risk
factors and you can also see that uh now
after the area of vaccines we also have
protected Peppers that have negative uh
points that can decrease the predicted
risk and this provided us with very high
granularity more than 100 different
types of this is just one thought of it
and we could tell the policy makers
listen depending on the amount of
resources you have in each day
say this day you are giving the drugs uh
to people with 55 points of risk and
above so this will be correlated to one
percent of the population but the
sensitivity the record will be 36 and
the positive predictive value the
position will be 12 now you can allocate
the drugs and the pandemic levels are
lower you can allocate the drug to ten
percent of the infected individuals
every day so now you can use the capital
for 39 points and this is the
performance measures that you will get
in return
so this is something that is granular it
can accommodate different levels of the
pandemic and different allocation of
numbers of of peers that you can assign
to patients every day but it's
completely transparent and it allows
manual re-estimation in cases that the
Physicians say listen you've missed
something I know that this station has
COPD you do not know that because the
data was not accurate enough so now I
know how to adjust the calculated
probability that ran over the night and
to understand this patient is now
eligible to receive that treatment so
this is like a trade-off between the
Simplicity and exclusivity between the
transparency and accuracy uh the
performance measures as we saw are
pretty good but it allowed us to create
something that could be used by
physicians for the allocation of a
scarce resource that was very sensitive
their location was very insensitive and
thus had to be completely transparent we
could just not say this patient
uh is not eligible for the disease
without completely explaining why so
it's not like uh opt-in like the first
model these patients are at high risk
call them send them to hospitals but if
you want the same for other patients
that that's okay in this case some
patients it like opt out some patients
because of the model did not receive
resources that they wanted and it had to
be completely transparent and completely
clinical so this is like a summary of
the different types of models the
different uses and depending on the type
of resource and depending on the
sensitivity of the use of that resource
uh the it was very correlated to the
amount of its inability and transparency
that we had to create with conspiracy
had to come to a point in which manual
calculation was also an option in some
of the cases
um and now if we talk about academic
collaborations and potential questions
that we we want answers for is uh can we
create expressive Wonders that are also
explainable and and there is there a way
to overcome the spread of and actually
um we now have a collaboration with the
group
um in Berkeley actually uh trying to use
their uh processes in order to make uh
more expressive models to be more
sustainable as well
um I think I will skip this part just
say that everything I've just talked
about is used in practice it looks like
this this or the the interfaces in which
Physicians receive these recommendations
uh they've seen different intervention
lists for this case covid-19 you can see
the severity ranks and what we call
Proactive Focus so this is very
correlated to the parents question of
how you identify the risk and how you
rank the patients in a fashion that is
fair and once the person that the
physician wants to know why someone is
at specifically High predicted risk they
can press this question mark and then
basically what they see is a pop-up
window with the explainability of the
model and again depends on the type of
model uh the type of explainability that
we will describe and I will skip these
parts that describe not just who are the
patients the highest but also how to
treat them better and how to narrow
treatment guests for them
so
as just a quick summary we've discussed
why prediction models are important in
medicine we saw some examples for
prediction models in medicine and we saw
how we try to accommodate both model
fairness and sustainability in a very
practical medical use cases
so I think with this
I will stop sharing my screen and thank
you for listening
thank you very much in the interest of
time I think we can maybe accommodate
one quick question yeah
I don't know um Herschel Cummings here
um
so so when you talked well well like
cozy first amazing talk I'm like no
totally impressed at all of this like
impact of like you know translating
Theory into practice but I think I think
for by time I will hurry along
um
um so while you talked about these like
you know coveted risks of like you know
low risk high risk very very high I was
sort of
um
struck with a question that I feel like
is academics we are often faced with
which is which is there's like a
trade-off between like precision and
recall
um and anybody liked how you were able
to say here are these like you know
three separate groups very high high and
low
um and for each of those you can like
you know characterize various objectives
um and I imagine in your case because
you had like because you had like you
know concrete interventions and you can
treat these groups differently
those kind of like actionable
information
um
um
um how would you suggest people go about
making those decisions or kind of
thinking about how do you take this like
trade-off information
um when they're faced with less like
like
you know concrete tasks as a result of
that
so
um it's really interesting that you
specifically mentioned uh Rico and uh
and precision and the trade-off between
them because usually when I talk to
policy makers and I'm a physician that I
talk to Physicians that are responsible
not just to develop these type of
solutions but to actually make decisions
for patient care usually these are the
two measures that are most intuitive for
them so we basically present them with
these kinds of tables and sometimes as I
showed in a graphical manner listen this
is the thread of if we choose this
cutoff we identify six percent of the
patients at as high risk so we need to
have resources for X percent of the
patients and then the trade-off will be
will identify
I don't know why percent of the patients
that are actually at risk this is the
sensitivity or the recall and for each
patient uh what we'll have is a
Precision or positive predicted value of
I don't know Z percent and uh it depends
on on the trade-off because sometimes
the the intervention is something that's
um
is nothing that good so even if you have
a low Precision it's it's it's it's not
um uh you don't care about that
sometimes the intervention could be
something that is more substantial
something that has trade-off harm
benefit cradle and you want to have a
positive predictive value or a Precision
that is high enough and and justifies
that so basically when we create these
tables or these graphs and present them
to the policy makers with respect to the
specific clinical question they can do
the clinical math of what is more
important to not miss patients or to not
identify both false positives and that's
basically what they do and these are
actually the two performance measures
that are most intuitive for them as
opposed to say specificity and negative
predictive value
foreign
thank you very much
thank you very much so I think with this
let's thank Noah again
and now we'll break for lunch and we'll
be back at 2PM
bye everyone thank you